welcome to this video CP when yo cippec
we know from Brazil okay it's not
responding Jack d4 that's strong move
just strong as many others okay let's
see what we get yeah I usually prefer to
to allow the limbs oh don't care let's
get to the shuttle the samish
interesting yeah why not why not visual
basics of course so a normal way to to
play this however isn't so so popular it
leads to this typical formation from
between e kappa blanca which is known to
be quite good for white for very long
time
so nice g3 in order to play for you
guess so
I need to prepare you for he probably
will play Knight to c6 oh no this this
is a position of error a big one
actually he needs to have pressure
against the form now I will play a
player before next move basically
whatever is no it doesn't matter what is
player play for now I don't have the
balls to play it as pre move but yeah
this is the only move that needs to be
considered yeah i still play it age 49
and five is just too much takes on e4
INF Bishop g5 so terrible attack
yeah this is to say it's difficult to
defend this putting it mildly okay let's
see should I am can I already sacrifice
on g7 I can play nice h6 as well now not
not clear take care night takes yeah
it's also looking noise
okay Pete we need to play move they all
look look promising but I need to play
one of them a bishop age six someone
move I just just just just take it it's
still a very dangerous attack even if
this is probably not the most forceful
way to play okay now you can take your
right check so I played this
surprisingly quickly I mean probably oh
he didn't have a great alternative but
still now okay Jade made I'm thought
black forfeits due to this connection
yeah this is also a possibility gap just
disconnected etsy far as just it's just
very bad I think this is already losing
against good play you should should lose
now just just just simple as that it's
just too much i geti for and this is the
dream position in this in this opening
only hear you can you can debate what
what's the best I actually missed a good
good opportunity this is so this is
strong and and I win the win the night
yeah this is the the best way to play
probably but this is also strong it's
just too much here 97's the witnesses
have been in the game we can play this
but this is very
rarity juris to say the least so
everything on the king yeah compass on
plus four so there is some decisive blow
just around the corner okay thanks for
watching